mais d'abord retour sur cette énième
rebondissements à la mairie d'Amboise
nous vous l'annoncions en direct dans
notre JT d'hier et les élus de
l'opposition ont annoncé leur démission
jeudi soir lors du dernier conseil
municipal de la ville ainsi que celle de
leur remplaçant potentiel une nouvelle
tentative pour destituer le maire en
place Thierry Boutard car si un tiers
des postes de conseillers municipaux
n'est plus pourvu la commune doit
procéder à de nouvelles élections on
voit sa plus en détail avec clémencedosc
et Aurélie Renaud
rassemblez ce vendredi matin en mairie
les conseillers municipaux d'Amboise en
collectivement remis leur démission en
main propre les lettres ont été
réceptionnées et tamponnées les
démissionnaires se réuniront la semaine
prochaine pour préparer la suite
bâtir une liste ensemble de toutes les
sensibilités pour faire en sorte que
nous nous puissions répondre de manière
concrète aux attentes des amboisiens
vous connaissez déjà la tête de liste
j'ai quelques idées mais aujourd'hui si
vous voulez on en est pas encore là faut
qu'on s'entende et que ce sera vraiment
démocratique ce ne sera pas comme cela
fait à la hussarde le but c'est de
sortir de cette situation de blocage et
que pendant les trois ans qui restent ça
tourne à peu près correctement 2 ans et
demi il faut pas se leurrer on va pas
mettre des projets en place mais on va
essayer de redresser les comptes de la
ville on va essayer de la remettre sur
les rails cette démission ne semble pas
être une immense surprise pour les
amboisiens croisés ce matin certains se
disent prêts à retourner aux urnes afin
de tourner la page je trouve que ça fait
école maternelle dommage que les gens
t'entendent pas moi je pense qu'il faut
repartir à zéro et puis bon les hommes
voisins sont capables de Roboter il y a
pas mort d'homme c'est un conseil
municipal hier soir que Marie Arnaud a
pris la parole pour annoncer la
démission de tous les conseillers
d'opposition une décision qui leur
semble être la seule part de sortie
possible lorsque à ce point tout le
monde est d'accord pour aller vers cette
démission pour sortir la ville de cette
impasse c'est que nous n'avions pas
d'autre choix bien évidemment les 17
conseillers d'opposition positionne tout
comme leur suivant de liste une manœuvre
qui a pour but de rappeler les
amboisiens aux urnes comme l’indique
l'article l258 du code électoral il y a
un manque de plus d'un tiers des
conseillers municipaux et dans cette
hypothèse la loi oblige la mise en place
dans un délai de 3 mois de nouvelles
élections au lendemain de ce coup
déclare le maire Thierry Boutard
conseille d'une certaine tristesse et ne
peut qu'attendre l'enregistrement des
démissions par le préfet
pour les amboisiens et je crois qu'il
faut que chacun retrouve un peu de
raison dans ce jeu très politique à la
fois et qui engage la ville dans une
période sombre la préfecture doit encore
procéder à des vérifications avant de
dévoiler la date des futurs élections